venez avec moi les connections internet
avaient déboulonné
alors attention c'est parti de viol et
viol est ko et terminera pas vous
répéter bataille contre autrui noël
alors attention
giorgio on va démarrer pas bloquer
l'accord jean michel vous êtes prêt e
toujours attention c'est parti vous
passez et massa chacun votre tour ici
vous faites une petite danse et je
mettrai des points pour chaque équipe je
dirai quelle équipe a gagné
[Musique]
seulement
ouais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
quand je mets bien sûr rappelé aux
saintes équipe
ce carreau contre mercedes attention car
où c'est parti on y va au débat
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pas mal pas mal
pas mal attention vers 16h [ __ ]
[Musique]
la lie aux bonus qui met à palais qui le
touche pas ma pasqua
mme beerli alors là oui
on a donn solas sk mode chasse ont
choisi des relais c'est à vous c'est
parti olea merde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ses membres clés c'est bon c'est bon
j'en ai fait
violetta dans l'état qu'est ce que vous
avez pensé
les questions avaient comme ça lasse
d'esds sas laisse granda ce n'est pas ce
qu'elle a dit notamment appliquer ce cas
se regardent et knox à n'importe quoi
[Rires]
c'est pas bon je crois je crois je ne
parle pas espagnol mais je crois qu'elle
se fout de votre gueule
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
photo
là
pour toi
nous
il est bon
ah bravo domaine fois ici près qu'il
utilise
violetta contre enora et simon et
égalité mokhtar présentera cette équipe
et j'en fais entrer cette équipe allait
ou et laura c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'espagne n'a pas joué j'ai causés mais
sa balle et or tout compte
on peut tout faire et tout tout tout
théorie je suis si fier promet sa belle
balle et tout et tout petit logis tout
le monde attendait elle me regarde
bizarrement soleil on cautionnait pas
laissez moi je dis juste préparez vous
vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
il
la nuit
[Applaudissements]
t
[Musique]
voilà
la bonne nouvelle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
chérie je vais vous dire je vais vous
dire tuer pour mettre le point pour eloi
pardo qui est pour mettre le poids pour
un oral
il connaîtra pas à tirer
en attendant on se cale dans ce cas elle
pourrait non non non non non s'il vous
plaît moi je vais vous dire je voyais à
auxon hausse ou une nation après ce que
vous avez fait bien entendu vous avez
tout de suite vu le type d'animateurs
que j'ai terre savais que je pouvais tu
vois la soudoyer
c'est cet été blanc gaga des blancs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
là
[Applaudissements]